we're here at the massive festival of
techno lust and gadgetry known as CES
it's day 1 and last night was Bill Gates
keynote boring except for a guest
appearance by slash at the end he
totally shredded some of the cool stuff
that we've seen in press previews and
other things include Pioneer has a new
plasma TV that they're showing that
they're claiming has infinite contrast
ratio and what that means is the blacks
are totally black no light gets out just
like a black hole awesome huh imagine
the bragging rights that you'll have if
you hang that thing on your wall there
was also a wraparound monitor it kind of
goes all the way around your face from
alienware that'll be available later in
2008 it looks really cool if you want to
get totally immersed in your first
person shooters and be just the ticket
while we of course has some new robots
they've got this cool little thing
called the Tri bot it's got three wheels
and it spins around it's very funny and
very sassy fujitsu is showing some
awesome concept technologies including
what they're calling a fabric PC which
is sort of like a laptop except it's
totally flexible like it's printed on
fabric I'm not sure what the use of that
is but it's pretty cool and they've got
this interesting personal information or
a slit which just sits on your arm like
this it's got a touchscreen and you just
tap tap tap to find your next
appointment or figure out who you're
talking to or how to get to the nearest
Starbucks
and that's about it for today at CES
we'll be showing you some stuff later so
stay tuned
you